- So this Newsmax panel absolutely lost
their freaking minds when
some high school student said
"Allah" instead of "God" in
the Pledge of Allegiance.
- One nation, under Allah.
- Let's put aside that "Allah"
is just "God" in Arabic,
and that, correct me if
I'm wrong, but under Islam,
Allah is explicitly the
same God as the Christian
and Jewish God, as well,
and let's put aside
that multiculturalism and
the freedom of religion is
about as American as it gets,
but let's focus on the law itself.
For 80 years, under the First Amendment,
you cannot make flag salutes
and the Pledge of Allegiance compulsory,
and you can't make high
school students do it,
especially the way that
you want them to do it.
And perhaps one of the greatest quotes
from a Supreme Court case ever reads,
"If there's any fixed star
in our constitutional constellation,
it is that no official,
high or petty, can prescribe
what shall be orthodox in
politics, nationalism, religion,
or other matters of opinion,
or for citizens to confess by word
or act their faith therein."
I think it's pretty cool if
not exceptionally American
that this high school student
felt comfortable riffing
on the Pledge of Allegiance.